tell me about the onboarding process how
many wholesale renovations did you how
much iteration how many people
work on just that part yeah i would say
we've revamped it completely so a whole
new set of onboarding screens we've done
that
three to four times um in the history
and
when we first started this was six seven
years ago like you mentioned
the goal for onboarding at that time was
to minimize the number of clicks
someone needed to make or taps to in
order to get into the product and i
think that was the general
guideline for onboarding at the time and
what we found
was that when we were able to provide an
onboarding experience such that
users can give us some of their
information whether that's their profile
their goals their gym equipment and at
the same time we can
educate the user a bit on what they're
getting with this product
i think that starts to build the
relationship between
our product us and the customer and they
get bought and
they start to understand what this is
all about and they actually convert
better but
later down the line so we're adding some
friction to the process
but at the same time that information
transfer i think is really important
between the product and the user it's
like when you go to a new gym
and they on board you know hey what do
you like to do and i'm always just just
let me go in the gym
and they're just like if we just let you
go in the gym you're not going to know
about the rock climbing wall you may not
know about the massages you may not know
about the yoga class or
that we do breakfast in this place or
whatever and then you might churn
so they always want to walk you through
and give you the tour of the place
and that tour is good friction it's a
friction because it gets you more bought
into the product
and you knowing what equipment they have
and what their goals are
allows you to give them a better
experience than reduces turn do i have
that correct
yeah that's correct and it also starts
to build trust people know that hey
we're building this workout based on the
information they had given us
so it's actually catered to the
individual that's when we start to build
trust with the user as well
so now you've got the trust with the
user they understand what the product
does
you need to understand which customers
to go after
how did you zone in on or zero in and
rather
how did you zero in on and triangulate
on this is a fit bod
ideal customer profile i guess we call
it icp in the industry
i don't know what you call it internally
but what do you call it internally and
then how do you narrow in on
this is who we should go after yeah so
when we first started it's it's the
theory of the crossing the chasm right
you have the early adopters the small
group of people that are gonna be
the ones that are gonna spread the word
for you and then as you cross the chasm
you get into the
the larger majority where you start to
broaden out your targeting
i can tell you very early on our target
was very narrow
and it was quite simply lookalikes we
were taking our best users
we were sending them to facebook and we
were saying hey go find us another
you know 100 000 or million users
that are like these type of users and
send them over to us naturally we know
that
privacy laws with these ad platforms are
changing with with ios 14 and the whole
privacy privacy rules that they're
implementing and
i think that nicely falls in line with
us we're starting to
more broadly target different audiences
whether that's interest-based targeting
or other kinds of targeting where we can
say hey this is a product that's not
proven we have a social evidence of
people really enjoying this product
now we can actually reach the larger
majority different kinds of targeting
but definitely at the early stages it
was definitely starting small and then
growing from that point on so you have
the ideal customer profile when you're
starting
are the avant-garde the tip of the spear
the beachhead market
is people who are working out three days
a week who know what a burpee is who
know how to use different weights have
worked out with a kettlebell so this
product to them is nirvana they probably
are writing
their workouts down in a log book they
might what did people do before
fitbit would they log their workouts on
paper or would they carry a little book
with them what did you do
as somebody who was working out how did
you log your workouts yeah
no i had this issue completely i had a
pdf that i printed out
and i wrote on it so i carried a pdf and
a piece of paper in my backpack on the
way to the gym
and when that routine was done i would i
remember going to the gym and i would
just guess
i would take whatever was available i
wouldn't know what to do when i would
guess
and a lot of this is really what led
into the concept of
how we started fitbot which is to say
hey based on what you did in the past
we can actually use this information to
provide your next workout for you or at
least tell you what to target
for your next workout got it so you did
your bench press you did your biceps hey
let's do squats
let's work on your back or your abs or
something some other
muscle group so they can get a full
workout and you used to be able to say
hey here are our existing users
give me more people like this and the
facebook algorithm would do all the work
now the ad networks are going to have
less ability to do that
and that is a more acute issue for ios
users which i'm sure is the bulk of your
user paid user base because that's where
all the paid users are
so the fact that ios and apple has said
you can't track people
by their phones and what they're doing
on their phones facebook for your ad
network
that becomes headwinds against your
business correct i i would say
it's headwinds for all businesses but
from
what i have seen so far this has been up
for a month or two now what i've seen so
far
is a couple of things those businesses
that don't have a strong funnel
that going back to what we talked about
start from the top down where they're
trying to target everybody get people to
download and click and
start a trial or whatever but those
businesses that don't have strong
retention and strong conversion
i think they're now having a harder time
trying to
you know find the right audiences to
target so that's one of the
impacts and and the other impact that
i've actually noticed
is that there's a minimum threshold that
you have to spend
in order to get um what's called sk ad
network
attribution which is what apple provides
us and so this minimum spend is actually
in my opinion hurting the little guy
they can't get any sort of visibility
into their attribution until they have a
certain amount of spend
and so there's two these two different
places where i think are getting hit
somewhat hard and then you look at our
business i believe we have strong
organic traffic i believe we have other
channels that are driving
our users i believe we're able to target
in a somewhat
broad sense for for different
interest-based targeting
and still be successful and i believe
that our funnel is strong we're still in
a good place
there's definitely a shakeup in you know
the ad space
um for digital advertising and i think
that we're in a that definitely a really
good place to say hey the shake-up has
happened we understand what's going on
and our you know marketing efforts are
still stronger we're still actually
moving forward and growing our marketing
efforts
so but for folks who didn't know their
ideal customer profile
maybe they churn a lot of customers and
they were just buying ads willy-nilly
on the ad networks and letting the ad
networks figure out who their audience
was
that those folks will be infected a
little bit more this is my opinion but i
think so
imagine seeing a a commercial on tv
that's just completely not relevant and
not quite there
i think that's going to be similar to
what happens with with a lot of
advertisers
yeah it's interesting and very few
people are opting into
sharing their data with facebook because
facebook has some trust issues
and then i saw snapchat was getting like
70 or 80 percent of people were opting
in
because people who use snapchat are so
loyal to that brand that they're
actually opting in more
how much time and money do you spend
integrating a bunch of different
software products together at your
company
let me guess way too much time oh do is
here to help
odoo is a suite of business apps that
runs your entire company
on one platform they'll streamline your
workflow by bringing all of that
information together
plus odoo's integrations eliminate
repetitive tasks and data entry
if you only need two or three apps to
optimize your workflow
that's all you pay for odoo won't stick
you with the bill for apps you don't
use odoo has an app for every business
need
they offer 30 main apps that are updated
regularly in over 16 000
apps from their active open source
community you can keep your books tight
with their financial software
and their sales and crm apps will help
provide a clear and organized view of
your business
so here is your call to action your
first app is free forever
and right now odoo is offering a one
thousand dollar credit
on your first implementation pack that's
not a joke that's a thousand dollars
just go to odoo.com twist
to check it out that's odo.com
twist